hi I'm Joshua PI from science mission
today we have a doctor Felicia Ambrose
associate professor at the University of
Pittsburgh Medical Center is with us she
has published several research papers to
our credit and she has won several
awards I'll just name a few of them in
2018 she was University of Pittsburgh
Institute of on Aging best junior
faculty research award in 2013
presentation at the PT in motion
magazine featured investigator of the
cover article a growing concern again in
2013 regenerative medicine a key to
tomorrow's rehabilitation in 2013 Drexel
University Illumina profile
dr. Fabrizio mauricio combines passions
for physical therapy and regeneration
medicine in 2014
PT in motion magazine featured
investigator in 2015 Carnegie Science
Center a wold
awarded that she was awarded in EHS NIH
top paper of 2016 avoided aging cells
best paper of 2017 and in addition she
has received several research grants
welcome that ambrosia can you please
talk about your background education and
are sure so I was born in San Paolo
Brazil I came to the US and I've done my
training here in the US my baccalaureate
training was at Mansfield University
where I majored in biology with a minor
in chemistry when I finished my
baccalaureate my two main interests were
really my favorite courses during my
baccalaureate training were physics and
biology my father was my physics
professor in undergrad so I was
interested in kind of you know pursuing
some of those
topics I got an interest in
rehabilitation and applied to physical
therapy school and I also applied to do
a Master of Science Laval University
okay so I was accepted into both of
those programs that I had applied and so
it was a difficult decision what I
decided to do was defer my acceptance at
the physical therapy school at Drexel
University in Philadelphia to go where I
like the idea of kind of immersing
myself in French it was a language so
there wasn't too familiar with so I
thought it would be a great experience
uh-huh and so I was up in Quebec for
about a year and then I went to
Philadelphia and and in that second year
I actually did both programs
concurrently so I was although neither
program knew it at the time but so then
I I finished with my training and in
Drexel University in physical therapy
and I already was kind of committed to a
field and research ended up applying for
a ph.d program in Pittsburgh at the
University of Pittsburgh in the human
engineering research laboratories and
most of my work there was clinical
research but then when I got my faculty
position I decided to do more basic
science translational work okay and can
you please start tell me about your lab
people grad students postdocs so so we
have a nice mixture of trainees in the
laboratory
I have doctoral students from
bioengineering and also from
environmental health and occupational
safety some from the department of
medicine a postdoctoral fellow so we're
pretty diverse in our interests which I
think makes for very fun and lively lab
meetings each week okay and how do you
motivate them so one of the things that
we recently started in the laboratory is
that we have our weekly lab meetings but
we decided to launch what I'm calling a
in a
in Heroes series and hopefully our idea
is to kind of present you know very
briefly in 10-15 minutes an innovation
hero somebody who's kind of taken
chances stepped outside the norm and and
we kind of present this hero failures
that they've encountered and you know
kind of what does that innovation hero
profile look like and what does it
really be a creative mind and so it's
been a lot of fun we've had you know I
presented on Richard Fineman who is one
of my own personal innovation heroes but
we had presentations on for example
Freddie Mercury was a recent one so it's
a fun way to kind of look at the profile
of a successful and innovative
individual and it's also a great
opportunity to kind of learn more about
some of the personal interests of the
people in the lab okay and you mentioned
about your interaction with the lab
people in terms of weekly meeting and
all anything else you do to help them
out so of course we have a bunch of
informal meetings but the other thing we
do once a week we have sort of mini
meetings where we get individuals who
are kind of working together on papers
and so we have kind of paper focused
meetings where we kind of talk about the
data you know figure one figure to map
it out so that we can really be focused
on the story as a whole where we need to
go and of course we take the opportunity
to also discuss you know challenges that
we've encountered so that's been
something that we've been doing on to be
pretty pretty useful and let's talk
about your research like your work on
Clotho and all those things if you can
present your work that will be great all
right I'm gonna just do the screen share
then okay okay here we go
yep okay yeah so so my laboratory is
primarily focused on skeletal muscle
regeneration cascade
and and muscle stem cells and in this
particular project we're we're very
interested in understanding some of the
molecular and cellular mechanisms
underlying an age reduce age associated
reduction in a little muscle healing
capacity so I like to start with this
image because I think it really shows
the importance of maintaining you know
high levels of skeletal muscle
functioning over time and how much of an
impact it can make not only on physical
mobility but also on quality of life so
so actually we have learned a lot you
know the field has really learned a lot
about the skull and muscle regenerative
cascade in the last you know almost 60
years since the muscle stem cell was
first discovered by Alexander modal so
just a brief recap of what we know about
the skeletal muscle regenerative cascade
because skeletal muscle really has a
great capacity to heal itself after an
injury event so so muscle fibers contain
a very small population of muscle stem
or satellite cells now they're called
satellite cells because they have a very
precise anatomic location and that is
here between the basal lamina and the
plasma membrane and these satellite
cells reside in a normally quiet state
that is until a muscle injury or some
type of physiological stress actually
calls these normally quiescent satellite
cells into activation so once activated
the muscle stem cells will move to a
state of proliferative expansion really
to amplify the stem cell numbers at that
injury site these activated stem cells
will fuse together and they form a
actively regenerating muscle fiber that
is is characterized by as you can see
here this central nucleation and the
central nucleation turns out to be a
really nice tool for us to be able to go
in and histo
take a look at you know what are the
myofibers that are regenerating versus
those that are for example damaged or
even mature of these actively
regenerating muscle fibers though what
we know is with time the the nuclei will
migrate back out to the periphery and we
see this great restoration of the
quiescent satellite cells and so I think
the key thing is that you know when this
process goes well as is the case of
young healthy skeletal muscle what we
see is a very nice restoration of the
original structure and function of the
damaged muscle fiber however what we
know is with aging that regenerative
cascade becomes markedly impaired so
these are just histological sections of
cross-sections of young injured skeletal
muscle and olds injured skeletal muscle
as you can see here that central
nucleation that I I mentioned very
prominent with these nice you know
larger fiber diameter myofibers and the
young injured but what is greatly
compromised in aged skeletal muscle and
so we see that the myofiber diameter is
much much smaller and after time what we
see is that functional muscle fiber
regeneration is impaired and and really
characterized by an increase in fibrosis
profi broses at that injury site of
course the deposition of fibrosis is
important because fibrosis not being
contractile in nature will dramatically
affect the force recovery of that muscle
and so here this is some insight to
contractile testing that we perform in
young and injured muscle 14 days after
injury and what you can see is that the
force recovery of that old muscle is
significantly lower than the young
counterparts now there's been some great
studies that have really looked at the
cellular and molecular level to try and
understand this decrease myofiber
regeneration and increased fibrosis that
see with age and perhaps not
surprisingly what Brock had all
demonstrated now over ten years ago was
that with aging we see a pretty special
stem cells to differentiate toward a
fibroblastic lineage and so this
so-called myofibril myogenic - fiber
genic conversion is believed to
contribute to some of that increased
scar tissue deposition that we see in
aged muscle interestingly that myogenic
- fiber genic conversion has been
associated with and linked to an
increase in wind signaling activation
but there's good news and in that same
paper by Brock at all they demonstrated
that these age-related changes are
indeed reversible and so they did this
using a very elegant model of hetero
chronic para bios's where essentially a
young Mouse is sutured together with an
old mouse such that there's an exchange
of the circulating factors between the
two animals essentially creating a
Kaymer ism and and in this paper what
they found is that exposure of aged mice
to youthful circulating factors
significantly enhances the regenerative
cascade in large part due to an
inhibition of wind signaling activation
so these exciting experiments and
findings have really triggered the field
to take an interest in what could
potentially be the circulating factors
that might be contributing to this
enhanced regeneration in old mice when
exposed to use full-blood an important
aspect of this study was that they
demonstrated that it wasn't stem cells
from the young mouse that were being
transferred into the old mouse and so
micro environmental alterations owing to
this youthful blood in the aged mouse
seem to be really driving an enhanced
regenerative potential of the endogenous
stem cells within the old animal so we
became also after these studies
we also became very intrigued as as to
what might be some of the circulating
factors playing a role in this
rejuvenating effect of Youngblood and so
we turned our attention to one protein a
so called longevity protein Clotho and
we wondered if this could be potentially
a contributor to some of the anti-aging
effects of a useful circulatory system
we turned our attention to close though
because it was previously shown in fact
it was the same issue of science in 2007
that demonstrated that Clotho modulates
stem cell functioning and not only that
but it actually does so through
inhibition of wind signaling activation
and the same paper also implicated close
though is playing an important role in
tissue regeneration and so we wondered
if there may be a role for close though
in the skeletal muscle regenerative
cascade so when we started to look a
little bit more into Clotho and try and
understand some of the background we we
found it to be a very fascinating
protein so very briefly close though was
first discovered back in 1997 by curl Oh
at all and essentially it was a
serendipitous what they call a
serendipitous discovery where a mutation
and what they now know to be the closed
gene led to a rapidly accelerated aging
phenotype in the mice and so here you
can see the wild-type versus the aged
close though hype a morph and whereas a
wild-type mouse will typically live
about three years in the absence of a
functional closeout gene they found that
these mouse these mice lived
approximately two months and over this
time they developed just a myriad of
aging phenotypes including
cardiovascular dysfunction cognitive
dysfunction as well as a sarcopenia now
I think what was very remarkable as a
subsequent studies demonstrated that
over expression of the closeout gene led
to an
both lifespan and health span now
subsequent epidemiological studies have
also demonstrated that Clotho is
important for human humans and it's been
suggested that clothe those steadily
decreases in the blood stream of
individuals over time and
epidemiological studies have shown much
as was shown in the mice that lower
clothes though levels are associated
with cardiac dysfunction cognitive
impairment and what they show here
maintenance of skeletal muscle health
and so this was a paper that was
published by Simba at all in 2016 and
essentially they stratified individuals
according to their levels of Clotho
expression within the blood so they had
low Clotho medium and high clover levels
what was fascinating is when they they
followed these individuals for several
years they found that those individuals
with high close though levels in the
bloodstream actually displayed a geek
preservation of skeletal muscle strength
or a decreased loss of skeletal muscle
strength over time implicating Clotho as
potentially playing a role in the
preservation of skeletal muscle health
and vitality so we decided to take a
look at the the role of Clotho in
skeletal muscle regenerative cascade so
we started off just looking at healthy
uninjured young and aged skeletal muscle
and in fact this is just a cross-section
of muscle from the two groups green here
is in close oh and as you may be able to
appreciate we see very little closer
expression in muscle under conditions of
homeostasis however what we found is
that in young muscle following an acute
injury and this is 14 days after injury
we see a very robust cloth of expression
at that injury site however an aged
muscle we saw that that cloth of
expression was markedly attenuated
even following an acute injury event and
so that is quantified here in the graph
on the right side we also found that the
increase in local Clotho expression at
the injury site of young muscle was
associated with a significant increase
in Clotho within the serum but just as
we had seen locally in aged muscle we
saw no increase in circulating close
though levels following an injury event
and this is just on PCR looking at young
versus aged skeletal muscle at various
time points after injury so we have a
baseline three days after injury seven
days after injury and 14 days of injury
and just as we saw at the protein level
we see a dramatic increase in close gene
expression 3 and 7 days after injury but
that that change in expression is
blunted in the aged counterparts so you
know of course those studies are very
correlative where we see a blunted
closer response in aged mice and so to
begin to explore whether close though
may be having a more direct role for
skeletal muscle regeneration we turn to
a mice that were engineered to be
heterozygous lee deficient for clothes
of expression and when we looked at the
regenerative cascade in these mice
indeed we found not only a significantly
decreased cloth of expression at that
injury site as was expected but we also
saw that this was associated with a
decrease in the regeneration index or
the number of centrally nucleated
actively regenerating fibers as well as
a significant decrease in the fiber
cross sectional area and these findings
were consistent with previous reports of
an impaired regenerative response in
close though heads bye errands at all
which is actually published earlier this
year we then wanted to manipulate close
more local
within our animal model and so using an
shrna inhibition approach to close
though we inhibited local cloth of
expression in young mice and this is
just kind of validating that indeed we
see a significantly decreased close
though expression within the young
muscle after injury and when we did this
then we wanted to take a look at whether
a gene silencing of Clotho in our young
mice might impair the regenerative
response similar to what we had seen in
the closed heads and so here on the left
we have second harmonic generation
images which are just essentially on 3d
constructs of the myofibers in green and
collagen fibrils in red and so these in
these movies what we can see is young
healthy mice two weeks after injury
actually display a very nice
regenerative response as would be
expected so after injury we see very
nice myofiber
architecture at times I think you may be
able to appreciate the myofibers which
so a very robust a central nucleation
the myofibers are very dense and again
the organization is pretty nice here we
have a cross-section again allowing us
to see that muscle organization as well
as the central nucleation of the muscle
fibers now with these three DS
constructs then we can extract out the
myofiber channel and just take a look at
the collagen and essentially what we see
is a relatively small amount of collagen
deposition at that injury site again
which is pretty consistent with the
robust regenerative response of young
muscle but when we perform the same
muscle this is these are just
representative videos but when we did
the same imaging in the mice the young
mice that had received shrna too close
though what we see is a markedly
impaired regenerative response
essentially we see
a disorganization of the muscle fibers
we see a lot of of gaps much fewer
myofibers which display this active
regeneration and again collagen
deposition throughout here in the in the
cross section I hope you can appreciate
that there's a lot of spaces and and a
lack of organization once again we can
extract out the myofiber channel leaving
only the collagen and essentially what
we see is a an abundance of collagen
that really goes throughout that
regenerating area very reminiscent of
what we would expect with an aged
skeletal muscle so here on the right
side we have quantification of this when
we look at the number of centrally
nucleated fibers indeed we see a a
significant decrease when we inhibited
close though we look at at myofiber
cross sectional area and just to make it
very clear that this is myofiber cross
sectional area of the actively
regenerating muscle fibers and so we saw
that the actively regenerating muscle
fiber area was significantly smaller
than non targeting controls however it
was also interesting to us so we don't
exactly understand why that there were a
number of these large misshapen
myofibers also within that injury site
and these were not actively regenerating
so so then this increase in local closer
expression and and and seeing a
connection between cloth or expression
and the regenerative response next led
us to turn our attention to muscle stem
and progenitor cells to evaluate whether
the progenitor sub cells themselves
might be expressing clothed them so we
isolated muscle progenitor cells from
young and aged muscle and indeed
found just as we saw at the whole tissue
level a dramatic decrease in Clotho
intensity per cell of the age cells when
compared to young counterparts and also
we looked at close secretion by the
muscle progenitor cells just by
performing an eliza of condition media
from young and aged npcs and what we see
is that the young npcs are indeed
capable of secreting a closed oh but
that that secretion is significantly
blunted in aged MPC's so now some of the
studies in our paper had evaluated then
in these young and old npcs had
evaluated clothes role in cellular
senescence and justice has been shown in
other cells and tissues close though
seems to play a role in the attenuation
of cellular senescence so and we saw the
same thing in our muscle stem cells and
our muscle progenitor cells and so this
was really intriguing to us and it made
us wonder whether mitochondrial
dysfunction commonly associated with
aging and age-related tissue declines
may underlie some of close role in the
attenuation of cellular senescence and
so we decided to evaluate mitochondrial
function across our experimental cell
populations so this was a collaboration
with dr. ben van houten who's here at
the University of Pittsburgh and using a
seahorse analysis we evaluated the
absent oxygen consumption rate of our
young versus aged NPCs and indeed we
found a significant OCR in our aged NPCs
when compared to young counterparts we
wondered if we could supplement aged
NPCs with exogenously whether we could
enhance that oxygen consumption rate and
indeed we saw a significant improvement
and then when we inhibit in cloth of
expression in our young cells using an
SI RNA approach we saw a
that a lot lots of clothes though was
concomitant with a significantly
decreased OCR so the next we wanted to
take a look at the potential role for
clothes and the maintenance of
mitochondrial DNA integrity and so this
is a collaboration with Laurie Sanders
at Duke University and using a PCR based
method then what Laurie determined is
that again perhaps not surprisingly aged
MPC's display a significantly higher
number of mitochondrial DNA lesions when
compared to and normalized to young
counterpart levels however once again
just as we had seen an improvement in
the bioenergetics with supplementation
of Clotho to the aged npcs we see a
significant decrease in the number of
mitochondrial DNA lesions when aged npcs
are supplemented with exogenous quote
though and conversely we see that young
cells exposed to sa RNA inhibition of
Clotho displayed a significantly
increased number of mitochondrial DNA
lesions as compared to young scramble
controls but then we were really
interested in how might close be
affecting mitochondrial integrity and so
when we looked at this same model of
young scramble versus jung SI RNA
control si RNA cells that had inhibited
Clotho these are transmission electron
micrographs what stuck out for us was
that the mitochondrial integrity was
markedly impaired with a loss of Clotho
and again this is pretty consistent with
an aging mitochondrial phenotype that is
we saw the mitochondria were large and
vacuu elated and through this TEM it was
very obvious that most of the
mitochondria in the images displayed a
compromised matrix integrity we looked
at this a little bit more closely by
evaluating
- which is a phospholipid that is
primarily expressed in the inner
mitochondrial membrane and here whereas
we see a robust cardio life and
expression in our wild-type muscle
progenitor cells we see that cardio - is
drastically reduced in cells isolated
from our clothes oh headers I go mice
and again this would be consistent with
the loss of matrix integrity so then we
decided to evaluate whether potentially
restoration of the might mitochondrial
ultra structure and for this we used s s
31 which helps to inhibit cardiolipin
peroxidation and so we used three
experimental groups for these studies we
used wild-type mice our clothes though
heads and then closed heads that had
been treated with SS 31 for two weeks
these again the transmission electron
micrographs and I don't have the
quantification here but essentially
though the Clotho heads display a
significant increase in the number of
damaged mitochondria as expected ss 31
largely restored mitochondrial integrity
as as you can see here through these
really nice mitochondria with very
robust cristae morphology and again this
is is demonstrated here through the
expression of cardiolipin
what was interesting is that a treating
mice with SS 31 led to a dramatic
decrease in the number of mitochondrial
DNA lesions in cells isolated from the
close heads and this was also associated
with a significant increase in basal OCR
levels in the Clotho heads but of course
what we really cared about was whether a
restoration of mitochondrial matrix
integra
through SS 31 would restore functional
muscle regeneration in our clothes
though hats and so here it looks like
the labels are cut off but here on the
the Left we have wild-type mice in the
middle are the closed heads and here on
the right are the clothes oh heck that
have been exposed to ss 31 and when we
look at the number of centrally
nucleated fibers again it's an
indication of active regeneration we see
a significant increase when the heads
are treated with ss 31 we care about
function and so we use this hang test
method which essentially we invert the
mice onto into a bucket and we just
essentially measure the amount of time
that it takes for the mice to fall off
of the brain and when we do this
comparing the three groups of animals
what we saw is that the wild-type mice
after injury are able to display a
markedly increased hang time when
compared to the cloak X but that
administration with SS 31 significantly
restored the functional capacity of the
the heterozygous mice we then ask the
question whether Clotho supplementation
could enhance the regeneration of aged
mice in vivo and so we were really
excited by the in vitro findings
demonstrating that even administration
and supplementation of recombinant
Clotho could enhance the bioenergetics
of our aged muscle stem cells so we
wondered whether this might translate to
improved regeneration in vivo so we
actually started off the first
experiment that we did was to administer
Clotho via osmotic pump delivery and so
here essentially we implant
the osmotic pumps three days prior to
injury and these of osmotic pumps are
gradually secreting Clotho into the
animal and in fact we found that that
translates to an increased local Clotho
expression within the injury site of our
aged animals they're what we found was
that there was indeed a significant
increase in the act of the number of
actively regenerating muscle fibers
however we didn't see any difference in
the myofiber diameter of the
regenerating fibers when aged mice were
supplemented with Clotho via osmotic
Punk not only that but when we looked at
the images what we saw was that though
there were more regenerating muscle
fibers there almost seemed to be too
many centrally nucleated muscle fibers
and so we didn't see that nice long
train instead we saw that the muscle
fire stem cells seemed to be kind of
running amuck and so we didn't think
that this would translate to functional
improvement so we decided to go back and
do a different paradigm and that is to
look at Clotho IP administration this
time but really focusing in on the
temporal characteristics of the the
timing of administration and so we
decided to try two different groups
clothes administration one two three
days post-injury and these are all in
aged mice and then our second treatment
group was closed which was administered
on days three four five after injury we
chose this second time point because the
idea was to mimic that closeout gene
expression that we had seen in our young
mice and so essentially what we found
was we looked here at myofiber cross
sectional area and when we evaluated the
cross sectional area across the three
groups we see that administering clothes
though specifically within that three to
date five days post-injury window
led to significant increases in my fiber
area when compared to the other two
groups and this seemed to be
functionally relevant because as when we
evaluated force production across the
three experimental groups in this case
we used a inside two contractile testing
paradigm these are forced frequency
curves from aged animals saline injected
clothes administration from one to three
days and then clothes administration
from three to five days post-injury here
again consistent with install adji we
found that Clotho expression at three to
five days post-injury led to the most
significant improvement in functional
recovery after injury so taken together
then you know the summary of the
experiments that we performed this is
kind of the model that we're proposing
and that is that young muscle stem cells
are exposed to considerably higher
clothes though both within their
environment and they themselves seem to
also Express higher levels of clothes
though and that this close though is
important for inhibiting mitochondrial
DNA damage which drives a Ross
production within the cell and so in as
close as present to inhibit
mitochondrial DNA damage it helps to
preserve mitochondrial structural
integrity thereby allowing the cells to
more effectively move into a phase of
activation and participate in active
muscle regeneration
however with aging we see a loss of
Clotho and both within the micro
environment and within the cell itself
and that this is associated with an
increased mitochondrial DNA damage ross
accumulation and overall loss of
mitochondrial ultra structure and we
hypothesize that this helps to drive
cellular senescence and ultimately a
markedly impaired muscle regeneration
with aging and so those are the the main
conclusions of our paper although
certainly as we've conducted these
studies they've only led to a number of
other questions and so we can continue
to try and understand better some of
these connections and understand better
specifically the role for close though
in muscle stem cell health and
regenerative potential so with that I
want to thank my wonderful lab I feel
very lucky to be able to come in to work
with all of these individuals and this
was very much a collaborative effort the
first author on this paper is Emory
tasaku who is a doctoral student in the
lab and has been with us for a few years
now of course I also want to thank this
this project was as I've tried to
highlight throughout some of the
experiments was really a wonderful
collaborative effort with investigators
both throughout the university of
pittsburgh but also externally at
various institutions who have
contributed to these studies in some way
and i want to thank you for your
attention
thank you if you can okay
thanks it's a pretty nice presentation I
have couple of questions this closer
like how does it work do they act
directly like for example on the cell
membrane or is there a receptor or is it
at the genetic level how does it work so
so we don't exactly understand you know
how close and and those are really the
questions that we want to start to
tackle as a next step because though we
can demonstrate that close though seems
to be playing a role in mitochondrial
ultrastructure we don't really know how
that's happening and so that's a really
important I think next step for us to
better understand the mechanisms by
which it's happened and the vineyard
administered Clotho systematic sister
mccauley like injections is there any
blood has anything to like does it blood
Cleaves this closer because there are a
lot of proteinases
yeah in the blood so have you seen any
effect like with the longer term or
anything like that and the amount of
closer you inject so it seems you know
what we mostly focused in on is a close
of expression locally within the the
injury site and in fact we see that
systemic administration does increase
local close of expression one thing that
was interesting for us is that when we
did the local inhibition of Clotho via
shRNA we found a significant decrease in
circulating close though levels in the
young mice so suggesting that
potentially some of the clothes in the
blood is coming from the muscle and the
injured muscle and the last one is have
you looked at the gene expression of
fibers or anything like that to look
into like before injury after injury
because you mentioned about wind
signaling right it blocks the wind
signaling so have you looked at the gene
expression profiles of these different
time points in the heterozygotes in the
general general gene expression like
just look at the profiles like that is
kind of a fancy thing these days no so
we haven't we haven't done that in the
close heads per se although we have we
performed rna-seq analysis on young
injured muscle old injured muscle and
then old injured muscle that has been
that has received close though
systemically and so that's been
revealing some interesting targets by
which we think that you know maybe close
though is is having some of this impact
on on mitochondrial function so I think
it's definitely an area where we need to
continue to explore further okay thank
you so much I really appreciate your
time and effort and your presentation
would be on the website immediately as
soon as we are done so I'll send you the
link also so if you find any in some new
things coming out in the next several
months or so you can give us a hall we
can
do it again something new thank you very
much for your time and support for
science machine yeah thank you for the
invitation thank you